>> Hello.
Each day of the year, bad news coming out
of Iran.
Iran's government violating people's right
in fundamental ways.
Just yesterday, two young men, one at age
of 19 and another at age of
35, were executed.
And this is very sad.
Iran's government giving any excuse and force
them to confess against
theirself in prison.
Then later under this condition, they execute
them.
The government like to terrorize people of
Iran to not come to the
street.
I think this is responsibility of international
community, raise their
criticism toward Iran's government.
I think this is the right time that United
Nations Secretary appoint a
special envoy on Iran's affairs.
Human rights condition is getting worse and
worse in Iran.
And I am requesting everybody especially,
hold economic from members,
could take responsibility to raise the criticism
regarding human rights
issue.
Thank you.